- It's very, very scary
to be judged by the color of your skin.
It's happened to me quite
a bit my whole life,
you know what I mean?
Even how people describe me on Scrubs,
I'm the black guy from
Scrubs, you know what I mean?
I'm not even one of
the actors from Scrubs.
I'm the black guy from Scrubs.
And so I encourage everyone
to just, first of all,
educate yourself, that's most important.
You know what I mean?
Once you educate yourself,
you'll be able to see that,
you know, everyone
pretty much is the same.
We might do things differently,
but we all are the same
and together we can abolish
racism and it's everywhere.
And also, once you recognize that,
once you recognize racism is
everywhere, it never left.
It's always been here,
you know what I mean?
It's not a surprise that
this is going on right now.
It's finally coming to a
head is what's happening.
- Yeah.
- But it's been here forever.
And once you start, once you
don't take that for granted
and you recognize that
there's racism out there,
you'll start checking yourself.
You'll start checking
yourself, believe it or not.